absolutely critical week for kierstad
this week because of that by-election in
west yorkshire which i have to say
you've got to remember labor did
choose to call themselves so we've
teamed up with yougov to ask labour
members what they think
should happen uh and these are people
they're not voters they are the bedrock
of the party who pay 50 pounds a year
who go door knocking who vote in
leadership elections their view is
absolutely critical
so what do they think well in the event
that labour doesn't win badly and spend
and it's not looking good let's look at
the first flight
you can see that 41 of the labour
membership
think that kierstama should stand down
now that's less than the 48
that shay he should stay but that's
still four out of 10 labor members
thinking that if tomorrow goes
the wrong way for the labour party then
kirstama should
uh go as labour leader it's worth saying
by the way there are signs in this poll
that the situation in the north is even
worse
uh with actually more people saying he
should stand down if he loses tomorrow
in northern england uh amongst labour
members uh then should stay so that's
pretty great so what do they think
might improve the situation for labour
well look at this
we asked if people thought that uh andy
burnham
mayor of uh metro mayor of manchester
would make a better job and 69 percent
seven in ten labor members say uh that
they do think that it would be better
uh he would do a better job as labour
leader than kier stammer i think that
uh figures pretty grim andy burnham by
the way doing far better than any of the
other names
uh that we polled just to see how
kiersten was doing comparatively to
other big figures
look we asked how well uh labor members
how well various figures are doing
so andy burnham 94 say he's doing well
87
for sadiq khan lisa nandy 68 percent
angela rainer 67
and kirsten becomes bottom of that list
on 55
so why do people worry amongst the
labour membership quite so much let's
look at this
uh next slide the final slide and it all
comes down to this can labour
win again 21 now predict amongst labour
members that they'll win the next
election 65
almost two-thirds think they're going to
lose and after defeats in 2010
2015 2017 and 2019 you can see why these
numbers are extremely wondering for the
labour membership
and sam is it possible to say what they
don't like about zakir stahlmar is it
just
that he doesn't like a winner or is it
that they're real
ideological differences perhaps blair
writes who think he's not blair-right
enough and corbynites who think he's not
carbonite enough well the data
absolutely supports that thesis it's
like uh kierstama is under
under attack from both wings of the
party some other striking findings about
two-thirds of
labour members think jeremy corbyn
should be readmitted they think
many many of them think that the party
should return to that prospectus
uh in the 2019 general election which
lost the labour party so many seats but
seemingly attract so many
uh labour members but then there are
those uh on the right they are concerned
that lab
kierstama hasn't got the oomph he hasn't
broken enough with the jeremy corbyn
regime and hasn't set the direction of
the party
uh clearly enough and so the problem
here is that kirsten
appears to need to assert himself more
uh to
define himself more more policies and
more certainty and possibly even more
spending pledges should say though
it's not a done deal yet badly and spend
voting tomorrow and it looks like it's
close
it's close this is one of those
by-elections that will be done on the
margins
uh the conservative vote the vote on the
right uh is a bit uh it is relatively
united and
the danger for labor comes because uh
ex-labour mp george galloway
is siphoning off some labour vote but
the candidate who's joe cox's sister who
was murdered
uh in 2016 uh her sister is now standing
she has a lot of personal popularity
so it might be that she can do just do
enough
to win the seat for the party